Please welcome Matthew Dicks.
I'm sitting in a straight back chair
and I'm watching the greatest magic
show I have ever seen in my life.
The name of the Magicians are Clara
and Charlie, ages seven and three.
They have been preparing this
performance for more than an hour.
There are moving furniture and
gathering props and making costumes
and rehearsing relentlessly.
There's a table in the middle of the
room and they've put a blanket over
it and on top of the blanket there's
coins and cups and rubber balls
and an inflatable sort of rabbit.
And Charlie is walking around with a
cape made of construction paper that
Clara has taped all over his back
and they open the magic show with
Charlie saying, ladies and gentlemen,
just over and over and over again.
And it's amazing.
It's like a fantastic magic show.
The magic is atrocious.
They're like the worst, the worst
magicians you've ever seen in your life.
Like every trick is worse than the last.
There's, there's the disappearing
Charlie trick where Clara takes the
cape and she holds it in front of
Charlie and she says, abracadabra.
And Charlie runs and hides behind
the couch, but he doesn't duck.
So he's just standing there
laughing when the Cape falls.
And they're eating apples during
the entire performance, like big
apples and little hands and every,
like, everything's sticky and
like, it's so like decidedly less
professional than it really should be.
But the worst trick is the
disappearing dime trick.
Clara holds her hand out.
She's got a dime in it, and she
says, I'm going to make this vanish.
And she quenches her hand into a fist
and then tells us to close our eyes.
And so we do.
And I'm wondering what she's
gonna do with the dime.
And it takes a second before I realize
because she's taking the dime and she's
jamming it down my ear canal further than
anything has ever been down my ear before.
And after a minute she's,
she says, open your eyes.
And she's got the fist and she
opens it and the dime is gone.
And my wife, who is unaware of the assault
and battery that has just taken place to
the right of her, says, where's the dime?
And Clara reaches behind my ear
like a magician would to pluck it.
But instead, she digs deep with
her index finger and gets it out.
It's horrible and it's
beautiful at the same time.
And I look at my wife, Alicia, and
she's laughing and she has tears in
her eyes, and I know why she has tears.
It's because she's in the moment, like
she's in the now and she's watching these
two brilliant children do this thing.
And I am never in the moment.
I am a man like trapped
between two worlds.
I am forever looking to a future that
I do not like or want, and at the
same time, I'm anchored to a past.
I can't escape.
When I look at my kids
do things like this.
I cannot help but see these dark
shadows on the edges and I can't
help but literally think as I watch
them, that someday this family of
four is gonna be broken and one by
one, each one of us is going to die.
And this unforgettable moment that we're
having will one day be forgotten forever.
And I know that that is dark, like
that is as dark as dark can be.
And it's true, but it's, it's
not completely black for me.
There's a little bit of hope, there's a
light because there's tears in my eyes
too and they're not tears for the now.
There are tears from a past, a past
that has made me who I am, and it's a
past that gives me hope for the future.
In the summer of 1993, I was 22
years old and I was feeling great.
My life was finally getting started.
After high school, I had a lot of
struggles, but I was finally getting
ready to go to college, and that
meant I might have a chance in
making my childhood dreams come true.
And they were two and they were simple.
I wanted to be a school teacher and
I wanted to be a writer, and I fought
like hell to get to that point.
And then $7,000 went missing at a
McDonald's where I was managing.
And although my boss didn't think I
had stolen the money and my boss's
boss didn't think I had taken it, we
ran into a police officer who did.
And very quickly I was
arrested for something I didn't
do, and I was put in jail.
And when I was arraigned in front
of the judge, I explained to the
judge that I was gonna lose my job.
So I wasn't going to have any money.
And I was gonna lose my home because
my friend was moving and I was
supposed to be going to the dorms
and that wasn't going to happen
now, and I would end up homeless.
And I didn't have a family.
I told 'em, I didn't have parents to
support me or anyone to take care of me.
But the judge told me that I couldn't have
a court appointed attorney because my car,
a 1992 Toyota Tercel, was nicer than his.
His words.
And so that meant I was gonna have
a $25,000 legal fee, which might as
well have been $25 million to me.
And all the things I told the
judge, what happened, happened.
I got fired from my job.
I lost my home.
I lived in my car for weeks and
then I caught a lucky break.
Friends, people who used to work
with me at another McDonald's, Mary
and Jerry, born again Christians.
They took me in, they found out I was
homeless and said, come live with us.
And I, I lived in a
room off their kitchen.
I shared it with a guy named Rick
who spoke in tongues in his sleep,
and Mary and Jerry's indoor pet goat.
It was actually the goat's room
before Rick and I came along.
So we couldn't complain really.
And when I got there it was okay.
'cause then I had a roof.
And when you have a roof, you
have an address and a phone,
and that means you can get work.
And so I got jobs, I worked
in an office during the day.
And I went to work at McDonald's at
night because even though I was actually
going to be on trial for stealing money
from McDonald's, this one was owned by
a man, Andy Chung, a franchisee, and
he knew I hadn't taken the money, and
so he gave me a job closing the store.
At night.
I worked 80 hours a week
for more than 18 months.
I barely saw the goat,
and over that time, and over
that time, I was just so angry.
I was angry at my parents
for not being there.
I was angry at a police officer and a
judge who had put me in this terrible
position, but mostly I was just angry
at the world for constantly reigning bad
luck down upon me at the moment that I
thought I was gonna finally get ahead.
And then everything changed on April 19th.
It was midnight and I was in McDonald's.
I was closing the store, the doors were
locked, my crew were cleaning up, and
I was counting the money at the safe.
I had another $7,000 in my hand and
I was stuffing it into a deposit bag
so it could be brought to the bank.
The next morning when I heard the crash
and I knew what it was, the police had
come a week before to warn me about the
three men who were robbing restaurants
in the town, and I knew about it.
My girlfriends McDonald's on the other
side of town had already been robbed.
And the Taco Bell that I could
see outside my drive through
window had been robbed a week ago.
And in that robbery,
they had killed someone.
So when I heard the glass break,
I knew who was coming for me and I
made the worst decision of my life.
I took that bag full of that money and
I reached into the back of the safe,
and I dropped it down the slot that
sent it to a compartment at the bottom
of the safe that I couldn't open.
And then they were in the room with me
and they had brought my crew members,
two Haitian brothers who couldn't speak
any English, and a girl named Francis,
an 18-year-old girl who I would take to
the prom a month later because her mother
didn't trust her with anyone but me.
And they had us all lie down
on this greasy red tile floor.
Three men in black shirts and black pants
and white sneakers and big black guns.
And they started to open the
safe and take out the money.
And they realized very quickly
that there wasn't enough money
here, that something was wrong.
And so they grabbed me and
picked me up and they told me
to open that bottom compartment.
And I told them I couldn't.
There's a, there was a plaque and I said,
manager, can't open owner has a key.
And they didn't believe me.
And so they started to beat me
with the guns and they started to
kick me and I pleaded with them.
That they would believe me
that I couldn't open it.
And then I felt a gun pushed up against
my head, and I heard one of them
say that, I'm gonna count back from
three and then I'm gonna shoot you in
the head if you don't open that box.
And as they counted back from three,
I begged this man to believe me that I
could not get the money as he counted
3, 2, 1, and then there was a click.
It was the loudest click in
the history of the world.
And then they laughed and I cried
and they threw me to the ground and I
tried to crawl away 'cause I couldn't
talk anymore and I couldn't breathe.
And they pulled me back
and they hit me more.
And then I felt a gun press into my head
and push my face down onto that tile.
And he said, this time there's a bullet.
And I'm gonna shoot you if you don't
open that box for McDonald's money.
So open the safe.
And as he started to count back from
three, I felt all the fear and anger in me
just roll over to sadness and to regret.
I was a 22-year-old kid on a greasy
tile floor and I was going to die
having done nothing with my life.
And I would be forgotten by everyone.
And when he hit zero, there was
another click and they laughed
some more and I just wept.
And then they were gone.
And for the next 15 years, I suffered from
post-traumatic stress disorder until I met
my wife and she told me that I probably
shouldn't wake up every night screaming.
And I said, no.
It's like my thing, like some people
collect stamps and some people
play tennis and this is what I do.
And she said, no, that's
not actually a thing.
And she sent me to someone
and I got a little better.
And six months after the robbery, I was
found not guilty in a court of law, and
I restarted my life and I was relentless.
I paid off my debt.
I got myself back to college.
And in 1999 I graduated and I
became an elementary school teacher.
And for the last 18 years,
hundreds of kids have passed
through my classroom door.
And in 2009, I published my
first novel, something Missing,
and I've published 3 cent.
A long time ago, there was a boy
lying on a greasy tile floor thinking
that his life was gonna be over and
he will have accomplished nothing.
And somehow I managed to make
those childhood dreams come true.
And yet so much of me now, like all of me
now, is still lying on that tile floor.
No matter how much success I've had in
my life, I live with a constant ringing
fear that there will be a day not too
far in the future when I will be in
those last moments of my life, and
that I will feel the same regret that
I felt that day in that McDonald's.
And so when I wake up every morning.
I wake up in fear that I will
not fill this day with enough
to make that regret go away.
I'm a, I've spent my life
chasing a horizon that I cannot
catch, and so that is what I do.
I fill every day that I have with writing
and with teaching, and with beautiful.
Terrible magic shows
and I hope and I pray that
someday it will be enough.
Thank you.